vous allez me virer tous qui est roger
notre vieux on va garder les 30-35 ans
femme jeu des galets tous les conseils
dont qu'on dégage il habite dans le 93
est un bonhomme en arabe on dégage oui
je peux pas faire un truc pareil
sommes un cabinet de recrutement
professionnel va pas faire
c'est la loi du marché comme on dit
nothing personal serait que les business
c'est beau se la joue au football mais
ça marche pas comme ça aussi c'est une
technique de déstabilisation avec rama
est suicidé à cause du boulot il est
clair et ingérable
article 23 de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme toute personne a
droit au travail au libre choix de son
travail des conditions équitables et
satisfaisantes de travail et à la
protection contre le chômage
tous ont droit sans aucune
discrimination
à salaire égal pour un travail égal
quiconque travaille a droit à une
rémunération équitable et satisfaisante
lui assurant ainsi qu'à sa famille une
existence conforme à la dignité
pour péter j
les syndicats pour la défense de ses
intérêts petite voix tournage allait
pointer à l'anpe